from a game theory perspective do you
think we're living in a simulation do
you think we're listening living inside
a video game created by somebody else
well i think well so
what was the second part of the question
do i think we're living in a simulation
and
uh a simulation
that is observed by somebody for purpose
of entertainment so like a video game
are we listening how we be because
there's a cree it's like phil hellmuth
type of situation right like um
there's a creepy level of like
this is kind of fun and interesting
like there's a lot of interesting stuff
going on
maybe that could be somehow integrated
into the evolutionary process where
the way we perceive and are you asking
me if i believe in god
um sounds like it
kind of but god seems to be
not
optimizing uh in the different
formulations of god that we conceivable
he doesn't seem to be or she optimizing
for uh like personal entertainment
or maybe the older gods did but the the
you know just like
basically like a teenager in in their
mom's basement
watching created a fun
right universe to observe
so what kind of crazy [ __ ] might happen
okay so to try and ask this um
do i think there is some kind of
ex
extraneous intelligence to like our
you know
classic measurable universe that we you
know can measure with convent you know
through our current physics and uh
uh
instruments
i think so yes
um
partly because i've had just small
little bits of
evidence in my own ex in my own life
which have made me question like so i
was a die-hard atheist
um even five years ago uh
you know i got into like the rationality
community big fan of les wrong continue
to be an incredible resource
um but i've just started to have
too many little
[Applause]
snippets of experience which
don't make sense with the current sort
of purely materialistic
um
explanation
of how reality works
um
is isn't that just like a humbling
practical realization that we don't know
how reality works
isn't that just a reminder to yourself
yeah no it's a reminder of epistemic
humility because i fell too hard you
know same same as people like i think
you know many people who are just like
my religion is the way this is the
correct way this is the work this is the
law um you are immoral if you don't
follow this blah blah blah i think they
are lacking epistemic humility they're a
little too too much hubris there
but similarly i think the sort of the
richard dawkins brand of atheism
is
too
is too rigid as well and doesn't
you know there's a way to try and
navigate these questions which still
honors the scientific method which i
still think is our best sort of realm of
like reasonable inquiry you know a
method of inquiry um
so an example um
i've two kind of notable examples that
like really rattled my my uh my cage uh
the first one was actually in 2010 early
on in um
uh quite early on in my poker career and
i
the the the uh the remember the
icelandic volcano that erupted that like
shut down kind of all atlantic airspace
um and i meant i got stuck down in the
south of france i was there for
something else um
and
i couldn't get home and someone said
well there's a big poke tournament
happening in italy maybe do you want to
go i was like oh right sure like let's
you know got a train across found a way
to get there um
and the buy-in was 5 000 euros which was
much bigger than my bankroll would
normally allow and so i
uh
played a feeder tournament won my way in
kind of like i did with the monte carlo
big one
um so then i won my you know from 500
euros into 5000 euros to play this thing
and
on day one of them the big tournament
which turned out to have it was the
biggest tournament ever held in europe
at the time it got over like 1 200
people absolutely huge and i remember
they dimmed the lights uh for
before you know the normal shuffle up
and deal uh to tell everyone to start
playing
and they played uh
chemical brothers hey boy hey girl um
which i don't know why it's notable but
it was just like a really it was a song
i always liked it was like one of these
like pump me up songs and i was sitting
there thinking oh yeah it's exciting i'm
playing this really big tournament
and out of nowhere just suddenly this
voice in my head
just it sounded like my own sort of you
know when you say you think in your mind
you hear a voice kind of right at least
i do um
and so it sounded like my own voice and
it said you are going to win this
tournament
and it was so powerful that i got this
like wave of like you know
sort of goosebumps down my body and i
even i remember looking around being
like did anyone else hear that and
obviously people are in their phones
like no one else heard it and i was like
okay
six days later
i win the [ __ ] tournament out of 1
200 people
and
i i
i don't know how to explain it
um okay yes
but maybe
i
have that feeling it before every time i
play and it's just that i happen to you
know because i won the tournament i
retroactively remembered it but or the
or the feeling
gave you a kind of now from the film
hellmuthian well exactly like it gave
you a confident a deep confidence and it
did it definitely did like i remember
then feeling this like sort of well
although i remember then on day one i
then went and lost half my stack quite
early on and i remember thinking like
well that was [ __ ] you know
what kind of premonition is this yes
thinking i'm out but you know i managed
to like keep it together and recover and
then and then just went like pretty
perfectly from then on
and
either way it definitely instilled me
with this confidence
and i don't want to put a i don't i
can't put an explanation like you know
was it some
you know huge
extra extra you know supernatural thing
driving me
or was it just my own self-confidence in
someone that just made me make the right
decisions i don't know and i don't i'm
not going to put a frame on it and i i
think i know a good explanation so we're
a bunch of npcs living in this world
created by in the simulation and then
people uh uh not people creatures from
outside of the simulation
uh sort of can tune in and play your
character and that feeling you got is
somebody just like
they got to play a poker tournament
through you honestly it felt like that
it did actually feel a little bit like
that
but it's been 12 years now i've retold
the story many times like i don't even
know how much i can trust my memory
you're just an npc we're telling the
same story this because they just played
the tournament and left
yeah they're like oh that was fun cool
you know cool next um
and now you're for the rest of your life
left as a boring npc in retelling
greatness well it was and what was
interesting was that after that then i
didn't obviously win a major tournament
for quite a long time and
it left that was that was actually
another sort of dark period because i
had this incredible like the highs of
winning that you know just on a like
material level we're insane winning the
money i was on the front page of
newspapers because it was like this girl
that came out of nowhere and won this
big thing um
and so again like sort of chasing that
feeling
was was difficult um but then on top of
that there was this feeling of like
almost being touched by something
bigger that was like ah
so maybe did you have a sense
that i might be somebody special
like
this kind
um
of
i think that's the confidence thing
that uh
maybe you could do something special in
this world after all kind of feeling i
definitely i mean
this is the thing i think everybody
wrestles with to an extent right we all
we are truly the protagonists in our own
lives
and so it's a natural bias human bias to
feel
to feel special and i think and in some
ways we are special every single person
is special because you are that
the universe does the world literally
does revolve around you that's the thing
in in some respect but
of course if you then zoom out and take
the amalgam of everyone's experiences
then no it doesn't so there is this
shared sort of objective reality but
sorry there's objective reality that is
shared but then there's also this
subject of reality which is truly unique
to you and i think both of those things
coexist and it's not like one is correct
and one isn't and again anyone who's
like uh oh no your lived experience is
everything versus your lived experience
is nothing no it's it's a blend between
these two things they can exist
concurrently but there's a certain kind
of sense that at least i've had my whole
life and i think a lot of people have
this is like well i'm just like this
little person
surely i can't be one of those people
that do the big thing
right there's all these big people doing
big things there's
big actors and actresses big musicians
there's big uh business owners and all
that kind of stuff scientists and so on
i you know i have my own subject
experience that i enjoy and so on but
there's like a different layer
like um
surely i can't do those great things i
mean one of the things just having
interacted with a lot of great people i
realized no they're like
just the same the same the same humans
as me
and that realization i think is really
empowering and like for you to remind
yourself
yeah
they're like a bag of insecurities and
yes
um
peculiar sort of
like their own little weirdnesses and so
on um i i should say also not
um they have the capacity for brilliance
but they're not
generically brilliant like you know we
we tend to say this person or that
person is brilliant
but really
no they're just like sitting there and
thinking through stuff just like the
rest of us right i think they're in the
habit of thinking through stuff
seriously and they've built up a habit
of
not allowing them their mind to get
trapped in a bunch of [ __ ] and
minutiae of day-to-day life they really
think big ideas but those big ideas
it's like allowing yourself the freedom
to think big
to realize that you you you can be one
that actually solved this particular big
problem first identify a big problem
that you care about then like i can
actually be the one that solves this
problem
and like allowing yourself to believe
that and i think sometimes you do need
to have like that shock go through your
body and a voice tells you you're going
to win this tournament well exactly and
whether it was
it's it's this idea of uh useful
fictions
so again like going through the all like
the rat the classic rationalist training
of less wrong where it's like you want
your map you know the the image you have
of the world in your head to as
accurately match up with how the world
actually is yeah you want the map and
the territory to perfectly align as you
know you want it to be
as an accurate representation as
possible
i don't know if i fully subscribe to
that anymore having now had these
moments of like
feeling of something either bigger or
just actually just being overconfident
like there's there is value in
overconfidence sometimes i do if you
would you know take you know take
magnus carlsen right
if he i'm sure from a young age he knew
he was very talented
but i wouldn't be surprised if he was
also
had something in him
to well actually maybe he's a bad
example because he truly is the world's
greatest um but someone who is unclear
whether they were going to be the
world's greatest but ended up doing
extremely well because they had this
innate deep self-confidence this like
even overblown uh idea of how good their
relative skill level is that gave them
the confidence to then pursue this thing
and they're like
with the kind of focus and dedication
that it requires to excel in whatever it
is you're trying to do you know and so
there are these useful fictions and
that's where
i think i diverge slightly with the
classic um
the classic sort of rationalist
community um
because
that's a field that is worth studying um
of like how the stories we tell what the
stories we tell to ourselves even if
they are actually false and even if we
suspect they might be false um
how it's better to sort of have that
like little bit of faith
um like value in faith i think actually
and that's partly another thing that's
like now led me to explore
um
you know the concept of god whether you
want to call it a simulator
the classic theological thing i think
we're all like elucidating to the same
thing now i don't know i'm not saying
you know because obviously the christian
god is like you know all benevolent
um endless love the simulation
one of at least one of the simulation
hypothesis is like as you said like a
teenager in his bedroom who doesn't
really care doesn't give a [ __ ] how
about the individuals within there it
just like
wants to see how the thing plays out
because it's curious and it could turn
it off like that you know
where on the you know we're on the sort
of psychopathy to benevolent spectrum
god is i don't know
um but
having
having this having a little bit of faith
that there is something else out there
that might be interested in our outcome
is i think an essential thing actually
for people to to find a because it
creates commonality between it's it's
something we can all
share and like it like it is uniquely
humbling of all of us to an extent it's
like a like a common objective um but b
it gives people that little bit of like
reserve you know when things get really
dark and i do think things are going to
get pretty dark over the next few years
um
but it gives that like
to think that there's something out
there that actually wants our game to
keep going i keep calling it the game
you know uh it's a thing c and i like we
call it the game um
you and c is aka grimes
called what the game everything the
whole thing yeah we joke about like
everything is a game no well the
universe like what if
what if it's a game and the goal of the
game is to figure out like well either
how to beat it how to get out of it you
know maybe maybe that maybe this
universe is an escape room like a giant
escape room and the goal
is to figure out
all the pieces of puzzle figure out how
it works in order to like unlock this
like hyper dimensional key and get out
beyond what it is that's no but but then
so you're saying it's like different
levels and it's like a cage within a
cage within a cage you never had like
kate one cage at a time you figure out
how to describe that
um like you level up you know like us
becoming multi-planetary would be a
level up or us you know figuring out how
to upload our consciousnesses to the
thing that would probably be a leveling
up or
spiritually you know humanity becoming
more combined and less adversarial and
and
uh bloodthirsty and us becoming a little
bit more enlightened that would be a
leveling up you know there's many
different frames to it yeah whether it's
physical
you know digital uh or like metaphors
i think i think level one for earth is
probably
the biological evolutionary process
it's like going from single cell
organisms to to early humans
then maybe
level two is
what whatever is happening inside our
minds and creating ideas and creating
technologies
that's like
evolutionary process of ideas
and then multiplanetary is interesting
is that fundamentally different from
what we're doing here on earth
probably because it allows us to like
exponentially scale
it
it it delays the malthusian trap
right it it it's a way to
keep the playing field get
lot to make the playing field get larger
so that we can it can accommodate more
of our stuff more of us
um and that's a good thing but i don't
know if it like
fully solves this issue um of
uh
well this thing called molok which we
haven't talked about yet but um which is
basically
i call it the god of unhealthy
competition
you